Après avoir parcouru 5000 km
depuis sa source dans l'Himalaya,
c'est ici que le fleuve déverse sa rage.
Elle a donné naissance aux chutes de Khone.
Leur débit fait partie des plus puissants de la planète.
Et pourtant, les pêcheurs laotiens se jettent à l'eau sans peur.
40 ans sans aucun accident.
Ce n'est pas un hasard, d'après Sam Niang, 52 ans.
- Je viens ici demander aux esprits
l'aide dans mon travail de pêcheur.
C'est indispensable d'avoir cette autorisation.
Sans cela, nous ne serons pas protégés pendant la pêche.
Les chutes s'étalent sur près de 10 km.
Les Laotiens appellent cette région Si Phan Don, les 4000 îles.
Des bouts de terre enchâssés dans les innombrables bras du Mékong.
L'une d'elles est le terrain de chasse de Sam Niang.
S'y rendre demande de l'équilibre,
et un coeur bien accroché.
- Comme c'est dangereux, il y a peu de gens
qui osent s'aventurer ici.
C'est pour cela que le poisson est plus abondant.
Et c'est pour cela que je prends le risque de venir.
Mon père, mon grand-père, venaient déjà ici.
Et moi, je perpétue la tradition.
Les poissons se reproduisent plus haut, en amont.
Quand ils descendent le fleuve,
ils se trouvent pris au piège dans les remous
des cascades qui les étourdissent.
- Ce poisson, on l'appelle le pat chok.
Parfois, il y en a des plus gros.
Et celui-là, il doit faire dans les cinq kilos.
Neuf heures durant, Sam Niang jette son filet sans relâche.
Il y a des jours où je peux pêcher une dizaine de poissons,
mais aujourd'hui, ce n'est pas le cas.
Et il y a trop de courant.
Ce n'est pas un bon jour.
À chaque fois que je traverse,
j'ai une boule dans le ventre.
J'ai peur de tomber. J'ai peur de perdre la vie.
Mais si je n'y vais pas, je ne pourrai pas nourrir ma famille.
Cette corde, en fait, c'est mon destin.
Je m'agrippe tellement fort à cette corde
que je ne sens plus mes bras.
Plusieurs familles se partagent
les eaux poissonneuses des cascades.
Chacune possède sa technique de pêche.
Noi et ses associés en attrapent une centaine
de kilos par jour grâce à une ruse imparable.
- C'est un endroit stratégique, car ici,
les poissons remontent du sud vers le nord.
Ils arrivent là et ils sont bloqués par les chutes.
Noi et ses collègues n'ont plus qu'à se baisser pour les ramasser.
Le courant pousse les poissons
vers ces ingénieuses rampes de bois.
Le Mékong abrite 200 espèces de poissons différentes.
Les plus beaux spécimens s'attrapent avec cette nasse.
Elle s'installe au milieu des rapides.
- Ce métier est très dur.
Il demande une très bonne condition physique.
Il faut être costaud, robuste et bon nageur.
Sinon, c'est la mort assurée.
Les chutes de Konhe sont aussi puissantes
que leurs cousines du Niagara.
- Il faut absolument être deux pour mettre la masse en place,
car une fois mise à l'eau avec la force du courant,
son poids devient ingérable pour une seule personne.
- Récemment, il y a eu un accident.
C'est arrivé à un jeune qui était bon nageur,
mais il était ivre. En traversant, il a lâché la corde.
C'est ce jour-là, le courant était si fort
qu'il s'est fracassé sur les rochers.
Chaque année, deux ou trois pêcheurs
sont engloutis par le Mékong.
- Notre vie, c'est la pêche.
Ces techniques viennent de nos parents
et de nos grands- parents qui vivaient du poisson.
Depuis qu'on est tout gamin, on apprend à vivre dans l'eau.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai pris au moins 20 kilos de poisson.
C'est une bonne pêche.
Des journées comme ça, ça me motive
et ça me donne envie d'y retourner.
Lentement, les poissons disparaissent.
La faute aux pesticides utilisés dans l'agriculture intensive
et aux douze barrages qui jalonnent le parcours
du Mékong depuis l'Himalaya
jusqu'à son arrivée dans le delta du Vietnam.
Le Laos est essentiellement bouddhiste.
Une fois par semaine, Noi le pêcheur
et son épouse se rendent au temple.
Tous les deux ont des crimes à se faire pardonner.
- Dans notre religion, il est normalement interdit
de tuer tout être vivant. Mais pécher, c'est mon métier.
Je tue des poissons pour pouvoir vivre.
C'est pour ça que je viens ici.
Les bonzes nous aident à alléger notre karma.
Nous faisons des offrandes et nous demandons pardon
pour tous les animaux que j'ai tués.
- Mon mari ne peut pas faire d'autre métier.
Notre survie dépend de la pêche.
Donc, je prie pour lui, pour qu'il ne lui arrive rien.
Leurs prières ne pourront rien contre la construction
du barrage géant qui va engloutir toute la région,
mettant fin à la formidable source de vie
que représentent les chutes de Konhe.
Noi et les autres pêcheurs devront trouver
d'autres méthodes de pêche pour se nourrir.